so as we continue into part two of DC
vs. marvel this is where we begin to
transition away from our discussion on
heroes and villains from the DC Universe
who have been transported to marvel and
those from Marvel who have been
transported to DC and we start getting
into battles between the most prominent
characters from both DC and Marvel but
the first thing we get here is a little
bit of explanation now I'm actually
taking this out of continuity in the
story because this is given to us later
in the story but I think that at the
beginning it's a really good place to
put this what we're told is that
unbeknownst to us as the reader at the
beginning of all things there were
basically two brothers one brother
represented the DC Universe and one
brother represented the Marvel Universe
and the result was that while they were
relatively aware of the other's
existence they simply chose to ignore
each other the problem is that because
they were two halves of a whole each one
desired to be unique and to be whole in
and of himself the only way for them to
do this or seems to you know seem to be
able to do this was to basically battle
one another and the loser would have
their universe wiped out and so that's
exactly what they've done they've
basically created kind of a battleground
using the characters of the Marvel and
the DC Universe and they've chosen to
pit them against one another and whoever
loses basically loses their reality now
one distinction to make here is that
this is not a battle to the death this
is simply an instance of proving who's
superior so all that's really necessary
is for one hero to knock out the other
in order to gain the victory so you know
Thor doesn't have to kill Shazam he just
has to overpower and knock him out and
so you're going to see that in the story
you're not really going to see you know
characters killing each other you're
gonna see characters knocking each other
out now the reason behind this is
something that I'm not 100% sure of
because finding interviews from writers
you know from Peter David or Ron Mars
who wrote this story uh it is difficult
at best and so there really isn't a
definitive explanation coming from
either publisher on why this decision
was made but if I had to hazard a guess
I would say because this was targeted
towards kids and you know even though
the comics code Authority wasn't really
in existence even though there weren't
really rules on the kind of Content that
comics could display in terms of
violence there was still just sort of a
social contract there was just a measure
of decorum
you couldn't have characters just
killing each other arbitrarily not only
that it was difficult for fans to make a
distinguish difference between what's in
continuity and was out of continuity and
so if in this story
Wolverine had died and then he showed up
in the Marvel Universe prospective
readers would have been like well what
happened why is Wolverine not dead I
thought he died in Marvel vs. DC and so
you know for that reason again I'm just
kind of speculating here I'm just sort
of spitballing with you guys in truth
you're your answer it's as good as mine
but after this exposition is given to us
we basically pick up with Wolverine and
Killer Croc battling one another now and
this is really just again another
situation of these characters just
fighting just just these characters
battling this is just again showing us
that Marvel and DC the the swish is
taking place is requiring these heroes
to cope with their own situations from
here we actually end up jumping to
Thanos and Thanos is again just
monitoring the fluctuations of the
universe itself now what we're told is
if Thanos is actually sort of happy
about what's happening here and the
reason why is because again this is a
point in Thanos his history where he's
constantly trying to appease mistress
death and he's constantly trying to end
life as best he can in order to make
mistress death as happy as he can and so
they see the universe fluctuating
presents two scenarios one it presents
the ability for him to rise to power by
capitalizing on the confusion that
everyone's experiencing and two it
allows him to use one of these
fluctuations are for the purpose of just
destroying the universe and everybody in
it which again would go towards making
mistress death happy the problem is that
while Thanos is analyzing this darkside
shows up when a boom tube opens up now
we don't immediately find out what
happens between these two but I will say
that later on down the line the Infinity
Gauntlet gets involved which is uh it's
both really cool but it's a huge letdown
at the same time but from here we jump
to a Captain America and Bane now the
the Captain America and Bane section is
again just a segment of the comic just a
segment of the battle between the two um
you know this is this is designed to
show us or the two of them are simply
just going at it they're still fighting
one another and that's basically what
this is it just gives us small little
highlights you know here and there
between these two characters we switch
to agus we switch back to Wolverine and
you know and Killer Croc going against
one another and as the two of them are
battling they're basically being watched
by
Grayson big Grayson is watching this
entire series of events unfold and from
his perspective you know as as Nightwing
at this point in time watching over
Bludhaven he's just kind of like okay
this is pretty wild but you know it
seems as though even if Killer Croc is a
bad guy if this dude with adamantium
claws or I guess you know from from dick
races perspective metal claws is tearing
through you know Killer Croc and maybe
this guy is worse than Killer Croc but
what we also know is that while Dick
Grayson is watching these events unfold
that gambit is sneaking up behind him
and so from here we switch to storm and
we switch to Wonder Woman and it's
simply just the two of them encountering
Jezza for the first time now what we end
up doing is we actually switch back to
Captain America and Bane and this shows
us our first victory of the story so far
one interesting thing that happens with
DC versus modeling something that we'll
see a lot is we'll see heroes being
defeated or you know individuals
attempting to beat defeat heroes using
moves that they were most prominently
known for for example with Bane he tries
to break the back of Captain America in
the same way that he broke the back of
Bruce Wayne but there's huge differences
here Captain America is no pushover
granted Bruce Wayne is on a pushover but
Bruce Wayne doesn't have super-strength
Captain America does and this is exactly
what happens he immediately overpowers
Bane while he tries to break his back
and he simply just knocks him out when
he when he throws his shield and it
comes back and hits Bane in the back of
the head now again this is just another
example of how Marvel and DC are playing
the story fast and loose you know we
just kind of have to assume that the the
shield was thrown we know that Captain
America recalls his shield whenever it's
thrown and that's it that's that's all
we get he just knocked out Bane with his
own shield I know a lot of you guys
would probably want a little more in
terms of explanation or you guys would
probably want a little more in terms of
well how does this all work it's not
designed to be that way the story's
designed to be just action it's a fan
based story and so what happens is we
switch to Bruce Wayne and and you know
at this point Batman is basically
watching you know the lizard doc connors
analyzing the skyscraper trying to get a
grip of his situation but while this
happens Dick Grayson is taken by
surprise from gambit and so the result
is that you know Bruce Wayne basically
sides with Dick Grayson and ends up
going to save him instead of keeping an
eye on Doc Connors but what we learn
is that while this is happening while
they're distracted with what's going on
you know wha Bruce Wayne is checking on
Dick Grayson to make sure he's okay
Gambon and Wolverine steal the Batmobile
and again the question we would ask his
readers is how did they get past the
defenses you know surely the Batmobile
has defenses to keep anybody from you
know eating anybody except for those
approved by Bruce Wayne from using it
but somehow he was able to take it and
he was able to use it and in the end it
doesn't matter because again this is all
just fanservice this is all just what
happens in this in the this crazy
situation so without with gambit and
Wolverine taking off you know the
question is with this vehicle being as
powerful it is being as fast as it is
you know maybe they can get back to
Westchester maybe they can get back to
Charles Xavier and they can find out
everything that's going on
instead we basically end up switching
over to a combination of different
things what happens is we basically pick
up with Jubilee and Tim Drake talking to
one another we pick up with you know
this this explanation from access
basically telling us that this dimension
you know this this wall this barrier
that's supposed to exist between the
Marvel and DC universes is becoming
weaker and weaker and the result is that
because these brothers have noticed each
other because of the fact that these
brothers are now fighting one another
that in the end it's basically
collapsing everything around them and
all these heroes are going to have to
fight and this is essentially just
access you know becoming aware of the
entire battleground that these brothers
have made for the Marvel and DC
characters to fight one another but from
here we basically switch over to Thor
and Shazam now this was actually a
really interesting scenario to me and
the reason why I say this is for the
living eyes who are not familiar with
Shazam he is a character who derives his
power from the Greek gods so to speak um
you know he's got the strength of
Hercules and and you know so on and so
forth the idea is that Thor which
resents the other half of this equation
Thor is you know the son of Odin and so
it's like seeing these two European gods
battling one another based off European
mythology and there's a kind of respect
that exists between the two of them you
know they're simply not just fighting
one another arbitrarily instead because
they are so powerful they actually take
time to pray you know before they
actually engage in a conflict and so
while they're doing that we basically
switch back over to
a nose and dark side in my mind these
two were probably the most anticipated
battle of the entire conflict because in
the eyes of fans Thanos and you know
Darkseid are effectively the same
character in two different variations
this is how exists how it exists for a
lot of this conflict
you know Deadpool is basically you know
Marvel's version of Deathstroke lobo is
more DC's version of Wolverine you know
the characters are all influenced by
each other you know they're they're
designed for different reasons but in a
lot of ways Marvel's copied DC DC's
copied Marvel and that's one of the
reasons why this series was so derisive
and why so many fans read it because
fans of characters wanted to see their
characters win and if their characters
didn't win they would get angry and
that's one of the reasons why Marvel and
DC actually allowed fans to vote on the
outcome of some of these conflicts but
instead of a initially battling one
another Thanos and Darkseid actually
take wagers on who would win you know on
who would come out on top if the two of
them were to fight each other and so
from here we switch back to to Thor and
to Shazam and the two that we're gaining
engaging in a pre you know extreme
battle against one another a pretty
monstrous battle and with Thor and
Shazam we would expect it to be that way
just because of the fact that with his
hammer with milner Thor is a force to be
reckoned with but Shazam is no pushover
Shazam is effectively as powerful as
Superman depending on the circumstances
and so it's if it was really just kind
of a toss up to see who would come out
on top here the result is that while
they're in the middle of fighting at a
you know at a carnival and when the
ferris wheel collapses on to on destroy
Sam he ends up shouting the word Shazam
which turns him back into Billy Batson
of living as who are not familiar with
Shazam ah he was he was created after
Superman in the 1940s but he proved to
be more popular than Superman in the
1940s and it was actually because of a
DC a lawsuit from DC that Shazam
disappeared for you know 20 years and by
the time he reached you know while he
was originally called Captain Marvel
Marvel Comics already had you know
already trademarked Captain Marvel with
their own character and so DC started
calling him Shazam but whenever it is
that Billy Batson the teenager yells the
word Shazam he's bestowed with his
powers and he becomes the SU
here oh but there's pluses others
there's benefits and drawbacks to this
you know the first is that if he shouts
as a Shazam as Captain Marvel in this
situation he'll turn back into Billy
Batson which allows him to get out of
tight situations and this is exactly
what happens with the ferris wheel
collapsing on him he shouts Shazam
he turns back into Billy Batson and he
gets his wing out the issue to this is
that if he were to shout Shazam again he
would turn back into Captain Marvel but
also mighty has to do is stop him from
doing that and so the result is Thor
does this Thor basically takes away the
Lee Batson's ability to say his name
again and he seems to effectively be
knocked unconscious the issue here is at
his hammer
you know Thor's hammer is knocked out of
his hand and when that happens Wonder
Woman happens along and sees the hammer
and when she goes to pick it up it seems
as though she's going to be successful
in lifting the hammer for but before we
find out we switch to a conflict between
Namor and Aquaman now this is a trend
that I hope you guys are noticing Marvel
and DC are basically giving us
situations where characters who are
almost identical in nature are fighting
one another
Namor an Aquaman are basically yet you
know those they are two halves of the
same coin you know of course Namor was
actually around before Aquaman but the
fact remains that each have their own
legacies and their own histories in
their own right but they both hail from
the sea they're both kings of their own
dominions under CM you know they're both
kings of Atlantis and so the result is
that while those two are initially going
against one another we end up switching
over to - the flash - Wally West and to
Quicksilver now this is one of those
instances where the question is asked
who's faster the flash or Quicksilver
now at this time at this point in time
in Marvel and DC Comics
this was a legitimate question because
there were instances where Quicksilver
was extremely fast wildly fast and
because they had never met because they
had never crossed over there was always
this question being raised now at this
moment right now with like DC rebirth
and new 52 so on and so forth we know
Barry Allen is much faster than
Quicksilver we know while u.s. is much
faster than Quicksilver in Final Crisis
Barry Allen outran
you know Quicksilver has never done that
this also took place before the
storyline when Wally West outran the
universe and so this was a legitimate
question back then as to which one is
faster and of course the guns are really
stuck to here in the sense that despite
Quicksilver being as fast as he is he's
simply no match for Wally West Wally
West is just way too fast in terms of
his speed and he easily dominates you
know Quicksilver he takes them over
pretty fast it's really not a huge
contest here and so what we end up doing
is we switch back to Aquaman and to
Namor the Submariner and initially the
conflict seems pretty even between the
two of them you know the conflict seems
pretty straightforward the issue here is
that Aquaman possesses an ability that
Namor does not name or you know is king
of Atlantis he does have super-strength
you know he is a human Atlantean hybrid
but Aquaman has the ability to
communicate with sea life now that's
kind of where I'm gonna leave it because
I know it's a very touchy subject when
it gets when Aquaman fans hear people
say that because Aquaman fans you know
routinely say he doesn't talk to fish
you know whether or not he talks to
fishes are relevant here the fact is
that he basically communicates however
it is that he does it with an orca whale
and the Orca lands on top of men with a
submariner and seems to incapacitate him
and so from here we basically switch
over to the end of the comic and what
the end of the colleague does is it
reveals a few things the first is that
we are going to see Santos and Darkseid
fight one another but the second and the
most important thing is that Wonder
Woman is successful in lifting the
hammer of Thor and this is a huge deal
because she's actually the first
character that we've ever seen outside
of Marvel Comics to lift Thor's hammer
something that a lot of us didn't
actually think would be that she'd be
capable of but in any event again you
know like the last video I post a
comment down below let me know what you
guys think about this one so far I'm
kind of curious and yeah this this
series is really fun the issue is you
know I'm kind of a stickler for
explanations that I'm a stickler for
exposition and you know this story is
more action than anything else and so
it's it's kind of hard to do to explain
a lot of the things that are going on
behind this
but any of their guys I'm gonna go ahead
and bounce off here make sure you hit
the sub button if you new here
become part of the rock cordel polite
and leave a comment let me know what you
guys think and I will catch you all
later peace
[Music]
you